right okay thank you
once again good evening councillors
ladies and gentlemen and welcome to this
virtual extraordinary meeting of council
the first item for this meeting is
apologies
all members of the council have been
invited to attendance this meeting
to meet electronically and i have
received apologies for absence from
there
councillor walsh and from councillors
and st
lam rigby and wynn stanley can i ask if
anyone
is aware of any other apologies
i'll take that as a no and move to my
opening remarks
one reminding you once again of a few
house rules when participating in
tonight's virtual meeting
please remember to mute your microphone
when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chair that you wish to speak
and please only use the chat facility
for this purpose and this purpose alone
to on mutual microphone when invited by
the chair to speak
this extraordinary meeting has been
specially convened
to consider conferring the title
honorary alderman
to former councillors jane ball and ray
balker mbe
in recognition of exceptional service to
the council
i appreciate a number of you may wish to
speak in support of the motion
and express fond memories of both jane
and
ray and we will do our best to let as
many people speak as possible
given our other business this evening
firstly though i will invite the leader
of the council
to introduce the matter and then call
upon the group leaders to support the
motion
before inviting others to speak if they
wish
i would be grateful if members could
indicate whether they would wish to
speak
by using the chat option in zoom
i'm pleased to say that we have jane's
husband dr boar
and ray's wife hazel and his son neil
present with us in our meeting
and i think it very fitting for them to
say a few words this evening
proceeding to the business then i now
call upon the leader of the council
councillor andrew westing please
thank you mr deputy mayor and may i
begin by saying
what a privilege it is to be able to
move
the recommendation this evening that we
award posthumously the title of honorary
alderman at the borough of trafford
to two great friends of mine and former
councillor
mrs jane boar and former councillor ray
bowker
mbe um and as you said mr deputy mayor
we have
um ray's son neil um here tonight
dr peter boar also jane's husband
um president who are going to speak
later as well
as um hazel ray's life watching on
also so this is a very very special
evening for us and i think
um potentially a fairly therapeutic one
for us
as councillors too to be able to come
together to
remember two absolute titans
of this council to people who
if you were to consider um some of the
biggest
and most significant figures that we
have had on this local authority
since our creation in the early 1970s um
would be right for
at the top of that list and we are doing
things
slightly differently tonight mr deputy
mayor and that it is
um highly unusual i think to confer such
titles posthumously
but when you hear from the members who
will contribute tonight about the
scale of the contribution that these two
individuals made to our borough i'm sure
that all members
will undoubtedly feel able to support
this nomination
it's traditional for such nominations to
come into myself as leader of the
council but i felt very strongly about
this personally
and wanted to nominate both individuals
myself
because of the work that they have done
for our borough and i'm delighted that
the mayor who's not able to
be with us felt-minded to allow this to
come
before council but i'd just briefly say
a little um
about ray and jane ray served on this
local authority
for spun 42 years long before i was born
and he had a tremendous amount of
passion
for his work in this local authority as
a counsellor for timperley where he had
lived all of his life representing
the village ward for our young people
through the way in which he conducted
his business as a councillor always
speaking up for them
but also in his roles as a governor
including chair of governors at
broomewood primary school
and of course his long-standing
commitment and diligent work with the
boys brigade
he really was a passionate advocate for
them and for all things
trafford he had a real desire as
somebody who came on
when our borough was um fairly new um
indeed as a founding member of the
council to make things
work as a collective in trafford and he
was
absolutely instrumental in making sure
that that was the case
personally ray was also a very good
friend to me particularly
when we worked so closely in a
competency supply arrangement in 2018 19
and i found him
always extremely honest and
straightforward
to deal with steadfast in his beliefs
and his values and somebody who
could always always be trusted he's very
suddenly missed
and few people could ever hope to match
the contribution that he has made
to this council turning to
um council mrs bohr jane is somebody who
um i still come to terms with the fact
that she's not here she was
as members know my ward colleague for
some nine years but she was also
a long-standing family friend somebody
who i had known
my entire life who i think
my mum who is on the call obviously as a
local counselor
succeeding jane in broad heath ward
actually had been friends with since
the mid-1980s and who made a tremendous
contribution
not only to the civic life of this
borough likewise
um councillor bowker as a former mayor
of trafford
but also as a exec
an executive member on more than one
occasion and
covering a range of portfolios and with
real passion
both in her role representing firstly
broad heath and laterally in my own ward
of priory
she was a strong advocate for the arts
and also for our young people
but anything that jane felt strongly
about boy did we know it
and boy did she fight for it um
it is incredibly um
personal for me to think of the
contribution that jane made not only to
this council
but to encouraging other people and
particularly younger people
to come forward and put themselves up
for election and to seek
to become councillors themselves she was
an enormous
supporter of getting young people
involved in politics
and some of the people who would not be
here but for jane's contribution mr
deputy mayor
and we'll speak later i include myself
in that
i include my mother in that who endured
a relentless
recruitment campaign from jane back in
2011 to encourage her to stand
but also councillors ross taylor dr carr
and others
who may contribute later she was an
enormous
figure um in trafford somebody who
made a real difference somebody who also
stood for
parliament twice in ultimate sale west
coming close
to victory on one of those occasions so
um i do miss her tremendously i was very
proud to call her
a friend and a trusted colleague and i
know that um
it's not the same in prior reward for
for barry and i even
12 months on so in summing up
mr deputy mayor we are looking here at
two people
who have been mayors of our borough who
have in my view
given incredible service to the people
and communities of trafford
and who could not be more deserving if
we tried to imagine
what more they could possibly have done
theirs is an exceptional story of public
service and i am delighted to know
that they become honorary alderman this
evening thank you mr deputy now
thank you i now call upon councillor
evans to second the motion
thank you mr mayor and on behalf of the
conservative
group i would like to support the
posthumous alderman status
the council of boar and councillor boca
when many think of councillor boar no
doubt like me
they think of her passion for the arts
and music cell waterside was part of
that
jane played no small part in the
waterside's refurbishment of 2004.
waterside is our precious gem quoted as
in 2018 as a culture center of the north
of england
last year waterside which is
particularly relevant to tonight
hosted trafford's holocaust memorial
event and the moving event
to a packed out audience many of which
were local school children
the theme last year being we stand
together
never before is it so relevant as it is
today
and many here tonight including our
former mayor robert chilton who spoke so
passionately at the event will remember
that very special day
jane like many knew its right apologies
jane like many knew it is right to use
our theatre to reach out and offer
opportunity to children groups schools
and communities
to make it so residents have access to
experience there too often
for the first time and it is thanks to
jane that we have such an amazing space
to host
art trails civic events and stage
theatrical events for community groups
and families
councillor ball was passionate about
community and that can often drive
people to become public servants and
councillors
as we have already heard that enthusiasm
catches on
and can lead to fantastic legacies jane
leaves such a positive
legacy here in trafford
and i know as i turn to councillor boca
uh that
i speak for the whole group let's cast
eyes over an impressive legacy the
council of boca
ray leaves behind a lifelong timpani
resident
family man and married to the lovely
supportive and loyal hazel
good evening hazel i'm sure you're
watching us tonight
ray who was first elected to the charter
council of trafford in 1973
mayor of trafford for the millennium
year which i know he was particularly
proud of
who was awarded the nba in 2002 for a
lifetime of service to the community
and now has a housing development named
after him
a truly formidable legacy and such a
successful life
a man of the community who fought for
the community who gave back to his
community
and stood up for residents please don't
imagine it was always the bed of roses
clearly we campaigned from different
perspectives as opposing councillors
but often could be seen working to get
together to deliver
real results for the benefit of all this
must be seen
of the best of both worlds and is a
testament to rey
two people here two different legacies
the conservative growth group holy
support alderman status for these two
fantastic councillors
thank you
councillor brophy i understand that you
would like to support the motion
on behalf of your group
yes thank you mr mayor and hope that
everybody can hear me
so i've mostly got some words to say
about both of them
but i'll start with councillor ball so
councillor
ball was an inspirational councillor she
made an incredible contribution
to trafford i first got to know her many
years ago before i was a counsellor
when she worked on friends of the earth
the environmental project
i know how committed she was to the area
to young people
and she lived in templeley for a long
long time she represented broad heath
and then priory ward
jane also shared with me a passion for
the nhs
she was a physio working as a ahp
my my profession as well i'm a dietitian
in hp
she was a role model as a counselor i
couldn't be more proud on behalf of the
book democrat group
in supporting this motion for her her
honor
i'm going i've got most words to say
about ray balker
and i have to say i've spoken to a
former colleague that many of you will
know
brenda mcroyd has um also um
wanted to to um contribute to what we
say about ray balker
it's really good to know that neil
balker is here
and i'm pleased to know that hazel is
watching from home
so as a councillor for trafford ray left
a record
of public service spanning five decades
42 years as a councillor
he was well respected across party lines
and regardless of our individual
politics
ray's record of surplus is an example of
anyone
in local government would do well to
follow ray was diligent in everything he
did
but never more so than his preparation
for his budget speeches
which i know everybody appreciated with
the seriousness and rigor that he took
that
role we will miss his experience
and his input as we deliberate our
future budgets as a liberal democrat
group
so in total i spent about 19 years as a
councillor with him
he was mayor of trafford in the year
2000 the
millennium year it's absolutely
befitting that council
shall convert this title of honorary
allman on ray barker who still
represents the very best
example of what it means to be a local
councillor
councillor ray balco mba he was a
one-off unique
amongst us he was singularly dedicated
to his community
a local person living here in trafford
before he even became known as trafford
ray went to wellington road boys school
in templeley
a school in which he retained a lifelong
sense of commitment to
and he was deeply involved in youth
services as has been mentioned already
with his membership of the boys brigade
at timberlee methodist church
and developed many leadership roles in
the boys brigades
so as everybody knows ray served on this
traffic council for many years in a
variety of roles
youth work always remained one of his
central interests
and he put much effort into the running
and improvement of the youth center on
the broom wood
as well as supporting other initiatives
like the boxing club and the local air
cadets
another of raised priority was always
housing
and as a council and village ward it was
always housing that
and the the that was ray was known so
phenomenally on first
for trying to help people with their
housing promoting
in the early days a huge renovation of
council housing on the timpy estates
it was his case work that he undertook
all the individual difficulties and
nightmares that he helped people to
resolve
which extended his reputation and his
breadth of knowledge
of local issues and local governments so
ray seemed to know everybody
in temple particularly village ward and
many beyond
and no knuckle cranny of village ward
remained unvisited and countless
residents
grateful for his help became supporters
and his friends
he had many qualities they're not always
graciously tolerant of dissent his
commitment to others into his team
enabled him to build a small army of
supporters who would deliver leaflets
for him help at jumble sales or organize
gardens parties
bray's calling was unashamedly parochial
he wasn't ambitious within the party
political sphere
he didn't take a great deal of
involvement in you know lib dem
conferences that kind of thing
concerning himself unwaveringly with
local people
local issues and local outcomes he built
good relationships with councillors of
many other parties
and of course with council officers he
served on many
public bodies as in mentioned just in
summary
it's with great honor that i'm here
supporting this motion for
ray balker to become um the honorary
alderman
thank you mr mayor thank you
councillor coggins would you also like
to support the motion please
thank you mr deputy mayor i'm i'm very
pleased to support the
demotion on behalf of the green party
group
and i didn't know councillor ball very
well and having only been cancers
together for a short time as
we we joined the council in 2018 uh but
i was always impressed by her passion in
the chamber
and i know from discussions and and
reading the tributes
and that poured out her that the words
that come up
again and again are a dedicated
inspiring friendly
welcoming um i know that she had a
lifelong dedication to the labour party
and um and she did served i believe a
remarkable 30 years as either an exec or
a shadow exec
member on traffic council which is it's
really a
quite quite remarkable feat to have done
um
and i know as well that um as we've
heard tonight cell waterside and
worthington park
were to um places that she made a great
contribution to
and uh and which are always mentioned in
in discussions about her
and so a former mayor of trafford and
becoming a
honorary older man is a a really fitting
fitting tribute
counselor bowker ray i knew much better
um indeed on the night that
dan cancer jerome and i were first
elected we ended up in a formal
semi-formal meeting with with ray before
we left the count in the very early
hours of the morning
and so it it was really the first thing
the first thing that we did
um and in fact um that became a
recurring pattern not meeting in the
early hours but um
as the two group leaders of the smaller
groups we often found ourselves
in the same meetings and and as a new
person i didn't know many people so it
was great that ray was always
a friendly and welcoming face and indeed
hazel at some of the outside events as
well
and as you've heard already ray had a
remarkable
knowledge and unrivaled experience on
trafford council he was elected for the
first time two years before i was born
and
i believe he served on nearly all of the
council's committees which is is
a remarkable feat and something for us
all to aspire to
and and he was very generous in sharing
that knowledge and as has been mentioned
before
and party political issues weren't
weren't an issue there he was keen to
help us to do
the best job we could we could do and i
know that these uh
these are felt back by all the the green
group and indeed the tributes to to
councillor baltu are felt not just by
the green group on the council
but um by the wider green party too
and i know that cancer bowker um has
particular passion for helping our young
people and was involved in the boys
brigade and
um and supporting young carers and many
other
um um charities for for young
people and i was very delighted to hear
that social housing development and
temporary will be named after him which
seems like a very fitting tribute
so again i think to have these two
former mayors and uh
uh honored tonight as alderman is is a
it's a fitting tribute to
to two remarkable histories thank you
[Music]
thank you uh councillor coggins i will
invite other members to say a few words
and if you haven't already done so
please could i have an indication in the
chat thank you
in the first instance i will allow two
minutes each but may need to reduce this
if time gets away from us i'll say at
the moment
i know that there are six councillors
who wish to speak
and i'll take them in the order in which
they've actually
put themselves into the chat box so that
means we begin with some words from
counsellor
barry brotherton thank you councillor
brotherton
thank you mr mayor first of all can i
just say
how appropriate i think it is that in
recent times the council has started
awarding
the title of honoree alderman
unfortunately in the past too often
the contributions of long-serving
councils were forgotten just by the
passage of time
that's not going to happen with ray and
and jane as tonight's
ceremony shows ray and i were first
elected to trafford in 1973
it seems like yesterday but obviously it
wasn't
and uh right at the beginning ray was
always mr timpley he was always
there to support people from timpani and
from his ward and
he as people have mentioned he was a
very big supporter of youth services
particularly when it came to budget time
ray could be relied on to say something
if
there were any cutbacks or damage as he
saw it to the community
use services jane and i uh
well i didn't know james actually was
first elected in in 1990 as a councillor
for broad heath ward and served
14 years as a councillor for that ward
perhaps a major achievement in that time
was as somebody mentioned
the uh the uh campaign for
sale was an art center i have to say it
wasn't universally supported
amongst all her labor colleagues at the
time but jane
by my usual power of force argument got
it got it through
even perhaps more uh impressive was
years later we had
seemed to have a lot of by-elections in
broad heath ward and i went around with
jane and i was amazed that
sort of nine or ten years after she'd
stopped being the counsellor there
people remembered her and many of them
thank the thanked her for the work she'd
done for them
sometime in the past and that really is
i think an indication of the work she
put in as a
basic world council dealing with
people's problems
jane came to priory ward in 2004 after
the boundary changes
she immediately got involved with
various friends groups
she was vice chair of sail festival a
chair of sail brass band
trafford parkinson's society and many
other groups
any organization that had jane on their
committee
was very fortunate she was no mere
figurehead
she would do everything organize things
sell your raffle tickets
organize uh your stalls and charity
stalls
and get other people to do it as well
she was a very formidable
uh organizer and worker for
the charities of the group she supported
uh in the end chair uh i i would just
like to say
i i served with james i think was doing
for 16 years in in prairie ward
i was really honored and privileged to
serve with her
as a colleague and friend perhaps local
councils don't uh have a very good image
with the public
but jane bohr and ray balker were
outstanding public servants
and they're very well deserving of the
of the honours we've uh
we're selling on them tonight i'm only
sorry that we do it in these
circumstances
but uh i do welcome the uh the honors
we've been sewing on them
mr mr deputy mayor thank you thank you
councillor brotherton
we have at least two more people who
added themselves in the chat box but we
move
to the next counsellor who wishes to
speak which is councillor
taylor thank you
thank you councillor boys mr deputy
mayor
it is a privilege and a pleasure to
support the bestowal of the posthumous
honor of aldermen of the borough of
trafford
on our former mayors colleagues and much
loved and respected friends
councillor ray boca mba and councillor
jane bohr
both embodied what it was to be caring
dedicated and selfless public servants
in particular i would like to focus on
councillor ball
jane devoted her life's work to helping
others
both as a physiotherapist and as a
counselor
she had my utmost admiration i
considered her a dear friend
and i miss her immensely i will always
look to her as the counsellor's
counselor
i'm deeply appreciative of the personal
kindness and
and generosity that jane extended to me
personally
however a huge debt of gratitude is owed
to jane
by the labour movement and the borough
of trafford
for her many years of unstinting and
outstanding service
with in particular her focus on the arts
recreation and leisure
and children and education
jane was an inspirational and
transformative boss
a role model particularly for aspiring
female politicians and i would include
myself as counselor
weston has alluded to earlier her
tyler's work ethic
her compassion her kindness and her
fearless ability
to speak truth to power were qualities
that radiated from jane
both counselor ball and councillor boca
liver
leave a rich and lasting legacy of good
in this borough and these honours are
richly deserved
and it is an honor to recommend them for
these awards
thank you mr deputy mayor
thank you councillor taylor uh the next
uh council wishing to speak is
councillor ross
thank you thank you mr deputy mayor um i
can think of no
two people who are more deserving of
this honor than
councillor jane bohr and councillor ray
balker this evening
um councillor balker a true public
servant
my local councillor in templeley for
many years indeed as councillor brothers
said
brotherton said mr timperley very well
respected within the local community
he was a colleague generous with both
his time and support of members
particularly new members and he was a
fantastic millennium mayor for us
one of my most visit vivid memories of
his that year was where councillor
balker doing a salsa
demonstration with um councillor jane
brought at an event in the in in ultron
and now i move on to um to my friend uh
councillor jane ball i remember very
clearly the first time i met jane as it
was
was one of those encounters that had
such a positive impact on my life
i was 15 enthusiastic about the labour
party and keen to do more as a member
jane was labour's parliamentary
candidate for ultraman sail west
and attended my school for a hustings
event where she spoke with passion about
the labour party and why she was a
member
at the end of the meeting i approached
jane to introduce myself and offered to
help
jane immediately put me at ease and was
both kind and keen for me to get
involved
she gave me her number and asked me to
get in touch and that there started a
political journey and friendship that
was
to last over 20 years in the first few
years it was a pleasure to campaign
with and for jane as a broad heath
councillor and then in 2001 where she
stood in north concert west once again
after almost making it in 1997.
after university i returned home and
jane encouraged me to take officer
positions in the constituency
and then to stand as a candidate at
council elections after a few years i
got elected
to council myself and was so proud to
join jane in the chamber
in jane's final couple of years on the
council i took the decision to put
myself forward to be bear
and i was so pleased when jane agreed to
propose me
and also so delighted we were able to
spend so much time together
particularly during sail festival over
the summer of 2018.
one of jane's final council appearances
was in may 2019 and i'll always remember
the lovely words she's had to say to me
that evening
i'm not sure my what my life would have
been had i not met jane at that school
one lunchtime in april 97. i expect i
would not have had
as many enriching and happy experiences
though
jane has had a wonderful impact on my
life and i will forever be grateful
i had the privilege to know her thank
you
thank you councillor ross uh and the
next speaker is and in
very rapid time also because we are
beginning to run a little bit short
is councillor chilton
thank you mr deputy mayor um i shall
rehearse what others
uh have said other than to endorse what
has already been said
um but um i would like to
just uh make a couple of remarks
regarding um
these uh superb counsellors uh late
councillors who are receiving this honor
tonight
um can there are very few in this day
and age i think
councillors who can be considered
completely synonymous with the areas
that they represent
um but um i think that councillor ray
bowker would have to be one of those
uh there are very few people um i would
say in the wider trafford area let alone
in timberley who haven't heard of ray
bowker
um and i was extremely pleased when i
saw that
the trafford housing trust was to name
the new housing development
um in the broome wood after him i think
those kind of honours
um are very much deserved um for people
who have contributed as much
to the life of the borough as ray um
when you
put on the the chain of office as the
mayor you are
very acutely conscious that you um
that you are wearing the same chain and
the same outfit as
people like ray and jane before you um
and that that is
it's very daunting um because here are
these giants who've done this job before
and you're sort of making a poor effort
at stepping in after them
um and uh one thing that i will never
forget and
i know that mrs bowker is watching that
i
um will preserve and carry with me to to
my dying day is the card that she is
that she sent on um this christmas um
when she uh talked about how much ray
enjoyed
the um the what what my mayoral year he
saw
and the way i was doing the job and
coming from
from ray that is quite something and
that's something i will treasure
very very much um for the rest of my
life
um and i will just say one thing about
jane um
when when there was any ever ever it
doesn't matter which party you were from
when you were when you were the mayor if
there was ever any information that
something wasn't being done properly or
any breach of protocol
um certainly on one occasion she was the
first to her feet
to intervene and to make sure things
were done properly for the benefit of
our mayor and the dignity of our borough
so so greatly did jane care
about our borough and the way things
that should be done and that's something
i think that they both very much had in
common
they honored our heritage and our
history um and
the things that should be done right um
so this this award i very
much support and is really really well
deserved on both of their parts thank
you very much mr deputy mayor
thank you council chilton we are running
short of time we move now to
uh councillor myers as the next speaker
thank you mr deputy mayor um as we've
heard jane bohr served as a traffic
counselor for 30 years
and it's fair to say i think that she
was a lifelong socialist
from a working class background and from
an early age she was chair of a local
young
labor group when she was in cardiff
and she later qualified as a
physiotherapist and managed to balance
her career
with her council duties during her time
on the council she held several
senior roles both as executive member
and shadow executive member
and before that as uh chairman of the
earth committees
in 2011 jane served as the borough's
mayor
i do recall several occasions when she
firmly managed to put me in my place
joan was passionate about healthcare and
was an active member of several local
organizations
she was the president of the parkinson's
traffic branch
and of the sale brass band and served
as the governor of several trafford
schools including park road
timpani in timperley and new orleans
junior school in sale
she was also interested in the arts was
a long-serving member of the sale
festival committee
as well as friends of worthington park
and of walton gardens
with our many years of service and the
contribution to the borough
jane boy is clearly worthy of the title
of honorary alderman
thank you mr deputy mayor thank you
council myers we moved to councillor
acton
you aren't mute david
thank you deputy mayor i'm grateful and
honored
to be able to say a few words in support
of the
proposals i've been fortunate to have
had the privilege
of knowing jane and ray for many many
years
and work very closely with both of them
and
i was struck when i first met them
jane and ray they were both
absolutely passionate and tireless in
their work as trafford councillors
and of course they were totally
committed to all the residents
who lived and those people that worked
in trafford
and particularly they were dedicated as
other people have said
uh to the people they represented in
their wards
also they both served as mayors of the
borough
and it is my belief that jane and ray
served the people of trafford with
absolute
distinction jane with a strong voice and
advocate
of many issues i will mention just a few
of them
education where she's just wanted the
best
life chances for all our children and
young people in trafford
and of course the arts leisure centers
libraries parks youth provision
music service the nhs and
much much more she was a champion for
all of them
and an absolute inspirational leader
in the community and an inspiration to
many of us here tonight and many of the
residents
across trafford jane and ray touched the
lives of many
many people in this borough in such a
positive way their contributions have
been
immense and i will finish by saying
i will miss them both ray was a great
character a great counselor and a friend
and of course i was very close to jane
and i miss her greatly
and when we finally get back to
normality whatever that
is and we have our meetings again in the
council
chamber i feel that there will be a
massive gaps in the room without jane
and ray i kind of felt
they would be there forever
and of course they won't be there in
person
but they will be there long in our
memory memories particularly my memory
anyway
and i think it's um
an honor for jane and ray and the
families um and it's well deserved
so thank you mr deputy mayor
thank you council acton uh councillor
harding
thank you mr deputy mayor just a couple
of words
from me really just some memories as a
newly elected counsellor back in um 2011
i recall feeling completely and utterly
out of my depth
at um how the council worked and and
how it all operated but i fairly quickly
hit the ground running
with the save traffic general campaign
but i recall my anxiety around public
speaking
around holding people to account and um
challenging people in charge really but
i always remember that jane took me on
one side
and she said to me keep on doing the
things that you're doing joanne you're
doing a wonderful job she would always
call me joanne
you're doing a wonderful job joanne she
was an incredible woman
and she was um an incredible champion
for women
and women's rights and she really
encouraged me
and other women to use our voices not
only in politics but in our communities
really
and i used to sit in the council chamber
and i would watch in admiration and awe
at council aboard as her steely
determination
shone through in her speeches
i would describe jane as regal regal was
out how i saw her she was always
immaculate and regal she was calm
she was measured and she absolutely
would not sit down
until she had finished saying what she
had to say i recall many council
meetings
where she was told that the bell had
gone and she had to sit down and
counselor ball would not sit down
until she had finished what she had to
say
i remember as a newly uh new executive
member again
jane took me on one side and said you
are doing a wonderful job joanne
keep on doing the things that you are
doing she really built my confidence up
and she would always always ask how my
daughter grace
was doing i miss her terribly
and um i am absolutely delighted that
this honor is to be bestowed upon
jane this evening and the people of
trafford have a lot to thank
jane for um she contributed amazing
things to this borough
it's international women's day on the
8th of march and i shall absolutely make
sure
that we speak fondly of jane and
remember her
on international women's day but i'd
also like to pay tribute to the work of
councillor ray bowker
again as a newly elected councillor he
would always
always take the time out to make sure
that i was okay
i don't know where i was going if i got
lost down a particular corridor
he had a genuine warmth about him and
politics were put aside as he made sure
that i was welcomed to council life
so as with council aboard the people of
trafford have a lot to thank councillor
barca for
fantastic contribution he made to
trafford life
and i am proud to be part of this
ceremony as we honour them this evening
thank you mr deputy mayor thank you
councillor harding we are now running a
very very short
time the next speaker is councillor carl
thank you mr deputy mayor both these
honours are incredibly well deserved but
i want to talk specifically
about my incredible colleague friend and
mentor jane bohr
growing up in trafford jane was well
known as a hard-working local councillor
at a time when it was relatively unusual
for young women to be elected
councillors
jane had an incredibly vibrant
personality and was an
absolute force for good she contacted me
personally to persuade me to stand as a
candidate
and acted as a mentor to me and i was
fortunate to know her well
as my own local councillor jane was a
great public speaker
and conveyed her passion to improve
lives and make a meaningful difference
to everything she said i feel so
fortunate
to live in the ward that jane
represented and though
i miss her i have daily reminders of so
many of the contributions
that she has personally made to trafford
jane has made such an incredible
difference to so many lives
but also her legacy includes the many
women and young people she's inspired
to get involved locally and represent
their communities
as well as the example that she has set
in believing in
and supporting others it is a fitting
tribute to both of these absolute titans
of public servants
that we are honoring them in this way
tonight thank you
thank you councillor carl um councillor
blackburn is it
were you wishing to say a few words
uh yes thank you uh mr deputy mayor can
i say
uh this evening my thoughts are with
hazel bauker who will be rightly proud
of the honor bestowed on ray
ray bowker mbe a kind and caring person
a man of honor and principle a person
with a sense of responsibility and
commitment to all the residents
a friend his presence and experience is
sorely missed
and can i say i'm very proud to have
known him
thank you mr deputy mayor thank you
councillor blackburn i just like to add
very
very brief words about each of the
individuals i
met ray balker first of all in 1980
in another world not to do with the
council and i can honestly say that as
far as that organization was concerned
uh trafford borough council came first
and that organization definitely came
second
and that was the way he was with it he
was a trafford council person
through and through as far as council of
boers concerned jane
i actually first met her as a
physiotherapist although she didn't
remember that when i joined her charity
committee
before i was a counsellor and i think i
joined that and gave peter a little bit
of support
because he previously have been almost
the obligatory
i must say that obviously we they have
both been taken before their time
and that short notice and will be sorely
missed
thank you everyone for your words and
i'll now put the motion to the council
that being of the opinion that former
councillor jane bohr and former
councillor raymond barker mbe
have rendered eminent services as past
members of the council the council under
the provisions of the local government
act 1972
hereby confers the title of honorary
alderman
upon former councillor jane ball and
former councillor raymond bowker mbe
in recognition of their exceptional
service to the borough of trafford
all those in favor
[Music]
ocean is agreeing in normal
circumstances i would now
present badges to honorary alderman
boar's husband and honorary alderman
bowker's wife
however i am happy they have been able
to join us to hear all our kind words
and receive formal recognition from the
council
dr baugh and ray son neil have both
indicated
that they would like the opportunity to
say a few words and i will therefore now
call upon dr bohr
thank you mr deputy mayor chris
and i'm really humbled
to be present at this occasion
um i can't read i mean i'm lost for
words
i mean the the tributes to both ray
and jane have been
phenomenal um i'm i have to
say that i'm going to have to rewrite a
biography
which i'm doing i've already published
three short volumes and i'm on the
third volume um which barry has just
received by we
transfer and jane and i met
in 1960 and we almost knew each other
60 years we didn't quite make our 55th
wedding anniversary she wasn't well for
the whole
of um 2019
and very kindly via andrew
uh leader of the council they allowed
her
dispensation not to attend council
meetings
other on other circumstances she would
probably get
be dismissed from the council but they
they weren't sure
how well she was and they didn't and her
own family didn't know that she was
she'd already diagnosed that she wasn't
going to live beyond
um 2020. as a physio
as sophie taylor knows
she would be able to diagnose her own
problems
but i i'm just smacked
at the way in which you've all rallied
around
and supported this occasion
um jane would probably have
refused an honor
um she wasn't a person that
wanted awards i did put her in for an
award
back in early 2000s
and sent a cv off i won't say what ward
she was
being put in for but she was actually
turned down you can't imagine that a
person like jane
would be turned down for an award but
she was
but as i say i'm not saying anything
about that
but um i just um i mean tom
has put it so well uh he met her as a
schoolboy
in 2000 uh in 1997
he very kindly wrote a piece for the
um the third volume of the
short volume of her um biography
and it's a it's really fantastic piece
which he's almost read
he reset tonight um well
all i can say to all of you um
congratulations
um we're so honored and hazel is i'm
straw and neil um
we're beyond words
in our and we hope that the council
comes out of this
situation so much better
than when we went into it because jane
just about made it to
to pass away just before the covet
situation was march 6 we actually
buried it in a in a
funeral um a burial ground in mobility
and uh the week after
we were in lockdown so we're grateful in
some ways that
she died when she did i don't i don't
say that
that she but it would have been awful to
try and uh
sort things out later than that but we
had a very nice
funeral for her and we
well that's all i need to say uh mr
deputy
on as i say i'm i'm honored to receive
this board
on her behalf thank you so much
thank you dr baugh for for those words
would neil like to respond
thank you deputy mayor and thank you
peter um for those
um kind words as well and thank you to
all the council members who've spoken
it's been
as peter just said it's it's incredibly
touching for both families
um i had thought this would actually be
quite easy and um
it suddenly suddenly got quite difficult
um not not long after
andrew started to speak earlier on and
it just got a lot harder when peter said
his very kind words a moment ago
and my father had many deep friendships
within the council chamber
and councillors serving currently and
councillors who've served in the past
and he'd be absolutely touched to hear
all these very kind words spoken about
him
and as peter has just said it's
incredibly humbling for us
um to listen to the kind words expressed
and it's a privilege to receive
this award on behalf of my father
alongside jane ball
and who i remember and i also know my
father held in the highest regard
for many and all of the reasons that
have been expressed very generously by
all the council members tonight
and it's incredibly fitting that both
jane
and my father can receive um these
awards at the same time
for all that they've done for the
communities that they've served for so
long together
and i wanted to share two smiles with
you and possibly a third one as well
and i smiled when andrew said that my
father was straight forward
and i suspect me repeating that now will
be making hazel smile in her
lounge and as she hears this and the
smile
grew even wider and when almost in the
same breath
jane brophy recognized my father's
efforts on the budget speech
and if only you knew how difficult those
days were leading up to the presentation
of the budget speeches um
year after year and it was far from
straightforward and
great credit to hazel for all that she
did supporting my father
on those and i also smiled um when i
received the email beforehand to invite
me along tonight to say a few words
and it mentioned that three minutes
would be allocated and i immediately
heard my father speaking in the back
of my mind saying it's fergie time neil
we won't need three minutes
we'll get it done before then and i also
remember the number of times it said
three minutes we'll need
23 if we're going to get ourselves out
of this mess i wouldn't pay them in
washers
and as you know he was utterly dedicated
to support for
his favorite team manchester united um
and um i also just wanted to share a
very quick update with you
which um also has brought a major smile
to hazel and myself
and and family members which is those
that were able to attend the funeral
um 12 months ago on the 12th of january
um well
um father's um grandson
louis received an offer um from oxford
university the same day
12 months on from when he passed away so
um the gods were standing on
that day 12 months on that was something
very meaningful for family
and i know my father had been very proud
with with his grandson
um i also wanted to very quickly
recognize councillor evans recognition
of
togetherness and the emphasis that
whilst people in the chamber do have
their own politics
ultimately my father's probably one of
his greatest
um values was it was about solving
problems for the community together
um and jane also recognized this by
emphasizing that he wasn't necessarily a
politician with a capital p
and attending all the conferences but
actually he was just
he was in the council to help people in
the community and that's all he ever
really wanted to do
and i also spoke at the funeral about
the extended family that dad had he had
us
his immediate family he had family
members through the church and through
the boys brigade
but also through the wider and council
environment
so all of you and the wider beyond that
trafford community
it was a massive part of his life and i
know that he will be looking back on all
this
um in wonder and amazement and feel very
proud of everything that's been said
about him
and there's also been very many
heart-warming moments and since
dad passed away various accolades and
recognitions that have been bestowed
upon him
and has been mentioned of that in the
earlier presentations in particular
around broome with school
and social housing schemes in timperley
um
that would be really really honored with
all of those so it is
it's a really touching moment for myself
for hazel and for my sister susan
and for all of our family and a great
honour to receive
on behalf of my late father the honorary
alderman of the borough
and thank you very much and we really
appreciate if you said this evening
thank you very much neil for those words
on behalf of the council
i'd like to thank you for your words
this evening
and say that i am honored to have
chaired our meeting this evening
where we have paid tribute and
recognized the great achievements
of both former councillors jane bohr and
ray baraka mbe
as truly outstanding servants of our
borough
that then concludes this meeting i would
like to thank all the members and guests
for your attendance
we will stop the broadcast of this
meeting at this point but i would ask
members not to leave
so that we can start our scheduled
council meeting shortly
you may wish to mute and turn your
cameras off whilst we wait to start the
next meeting
thank you why not